Let's not piss around. Here's my top five
tools in 2023 to improve your command line
life. Enjoy.
Tool number one is Xelage.
It's a terminal multiplexer like TMux, but actually
works for humans.
Let's remove my configuration
and restart.
You'll see we get an interface that gives
us everything that we need to learn how
Xelage works. You want a new tab? Done.
You want a new pane? Done. Done. Done.
Every time you enter a new mode, the
commands are on the bottom. Control t for
tab, control s for search, control p for
pane.
When you select one of these modes, the
commands are right below it. You can see
here x will close my pane. Zellege is
a fantastic tool,
especially paired up with a terminal like Alacrity,
which is super fast, GPU rendered and written
in Rust. What's not to love?
So go check out Zellege and improve your
terminal workflows now.
Next up, another tool written in Rust. This
time, Just. What is Just? Well, it's a
makefile replacement that doesn't suck. We open up
a Just file and it looks just like
a makefile. However, we can use something called
a default target called default. We can use
the at sign so that doesn't print out
each of the commands and also has a
mode where it can show you a chooser,
which we'll see in just a second.
There's no dot phony here at all. Just
appreciates and understands that people were using make
as a task runner. So Just is a
task runner.
You can set a shebang on any target
to allow you to run a script.
Here, instead of using bash or SH, I'm
actually throwing it through the Python interpreter.
So we can run just shell and we'll
actually execute a Python process and interpret some
Python code. We also have comments on each
of our targets.
These are shown on the command line when
we run just with auto completion.
And you can also have parameters to your
targets. Here, plan and deploy take a parameter
called stack which defaults to an empty string.
And we're just using familiar Jinja or handlebars
syntax
to interpolate that into our commands.
And just like Make, you can have dependencies
like so.
So if I run Just on its own,
we get the chooser.
If I run Just Shell, I get a
Python process.
No. Phony, things just work. Go check out
Just. This next tool isn't written in Rust,
but I'm gonna let it slide because it's
written in Go and it boosts my workflow
like no other tool.
Let's see the end to my DNS directory.
Now you'll see here at the top the
Dartenv
ran.
Why? Well, because there's a dot ENVRC
in this directory.
It has now loaded another ENVRC
because I told it to and then exports
a bunch of variables or environment variables that
I need for this project to actually do
anything useful.
Let's open this in Helix.
Source up is what tells it to load
any parent ENVRC.
Why? Well, I set my Cloudflare account ID
at the root of my mono repository.
So I want to propagate it to all
other services within the mono repo.
Next, export the Cloudflare API token pulling it
in from one password. Why? Because this particular
service needs it. Lastly, I'm exporting Rawkode equals
hello, just so I can show you what
happens when I make a modification to this
file.
Dartmouth tells me it's not going to load
it. It wants me to review and approve.
Like so.
Now we can do echo hello and we
get hello too. Replace your .env's with ENVRCs
and bring some sanity to your development environments.
Let's jump straight back on that Rust train
with Atuan. At least I think that's how
it's pronounced. A t u I n.
This replaces all the history on my terminal.
When I press up,
you'll see the commands I just ran when
I demoed Dart Enve as well as the
other commands that I've ran on this machine.
Specifically,
this directory, as you'll see at the bottom
left of the terminal.
Why do I want pair directory history?
Well, the commands I type are particularly context
sensitive.
When I'm in a Pulumi project, I'm gonna
run Pulumi up. When I'm in a Terraform
project, I'm gonna run Terraform apply.
When I'm in a Kubernetes project, I'm gonna
cry for help.
So use a history tool that gives you
the commands that you need.
But don't worry. You can hit control r
again for global search, control r again for
host search because Atowin supports
multiple machines.
Configure your shared key and show your history
across all your machines and laptops.
Lastly, session.
This is just the commands that I've entered
while recording this video. So go check out
how to win. Never have to type out
an actual command again.
Last tool, and I'm being selfish, it's one
of my own. Contraya.
It's a dot file manager.
Why? I wipe my machine almost every single
month.
Why?
I like to be clean. I like to
start fresh, and I like to make sure
that shit ever hits the fan, I never
lose that much. I use Contria to provision
all of my machines so they all function
the exact same.
It has cool support for variants, which means
I can have a single manifest that installs
Atuan, Zellej, Dartn, etcetera,
on Linux, Mac, BSD, whatever. It doesn't care.
That you can already see my Zellej configuration
already back to normal. Why? Well, the last
command I ran was comptria apply dash m,
which means I wanna run a single manifest
dev dot Zellej.
Let's take a look
at dev dot Zellej. Here, I define a
bunch of actions. One, package install. Two, config
install. Job done. You want to see the
variant syntax? Let's open variant dot yaml.
Here, I'm gonna run a command.
I set a marker to hello world, which
becomes the default invocation of this action.
Then I specify a variant where it can
use an expression language to compare the OS
name to macOS.
When I run this on a Mac, it'll
say hello from a Mac.
This time I'm specifying double verbosity mode so
that we can see the logs.
And there's my Mac. Quickly, comptri yaml allows
you to specify manifest paths that supports remote
paths too, the git repositories.
You can provide your own variables,
A DNS tool, red and rust.
These are real DNS text values on a
real domain from one of the maintainers.
Contria is awesome. It has too many features
to cover in this video, but you should
go check it out. I hope you like
these tools. If you've got tips for me
and tools that I should check out, hit
me up on Twitter. I've always got time
to play with something new. Catch you later.